alegría histórica aquí en Marruecos
después de la victoria de hoy contra la
selección de Portugal que otorga Los
Leones del Atlas el paso a semifinales
es una victoria histórica que no tiene
precedentes aquí en Marruecos la primera
vez que la selección llega semifinales
también la primera vez que una selección
africana llega a esta fase del mundial
este año en la selección marroquí como
ven está todo el mundo de celebración
equipo de todos sus tiempos y así lo han
demostrado hoy frente a Portugal con
goles de Siri y con una defensa ejemplar
aquí en la plaza de marrakech y en el
resto de ciudades del país se prevé una
celebración tan histórica como esta
Victoria Marruecos ha llegado a
semifinales todo el mundo está de
celebración